if we interpret the fall as the fall
into metacognitions in metacognition
then I would say empirically that's
obviously true
we broke our relationship with the
harmony of instinct
before we were prepared and what
happened was that uh we became able to
develop technology because of
metacognition
but without the empathy required to
apply the technology wisely as opposed
to that very narrowly contracted field
of personal benefit which is exactly
what we leverage when we use technology
so it's yeah the fall happened before
it was a good move on the part of nature
or on the part of the divinity
uh it was too early and the evidence for
that is life as we leave it today and
the risks that we bring to ourselves and
everything else that lives on the
surface of this planet
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Welcome to our Christ my name is
Marcus today I'm joining us again with
two brothers and gentlemen Jonathan
pajel and Dr Bernardo Castro Jonathan is
a French Canadian icon Carver Republic
speaker and YouTuber exploring the
symbolic patterns that underlayer
experience of the world how these
patterns emerge and come together
manifest in religion art and popular
culture he's also the editor of the
Athletics Arts Journal host of symbolic
World blogging podcast Bernardo is the
executive director of Essentia
Foundation his work has been leading the
Modern Renaissance of metaphysical
idealism the notion that reality is
essentially mental is a PhD in
philosophy and another PhD in computer
engineering so I suppose just to begin
then um I'd love to know really what was
what stuck with you gents from the last
conversation we had and maybe some of
the trades that you'd like to follow up
then
um if you start with shop Jonathan
I really enjoyed the last conversation I
thought that it was I thought that I was
able to understand bernardo's thought
more and also able to connect it with
the let's say the errors of thinking and
research that I'm involved with I'm more
I'm definitely interested in exploring
more of the the question of Mind as it
applies applies to
higher beings or distributed
consciousnesses the different ways that
people are phrasing it
um I've been thinking a lot about that
even more now and so that's something
that I'm interested in exploring still
seeing how we can make sense of agency
in terms of agency that appears above us
as humans
yeah on my side it was a delight to to
sort of get a live confirmation of the
fact that there are people out there
still that um consider it important
um to have a symbolic religious life
religious symbolism religious icons
um and consider it important to nurture
those as well
um I find it surprising that even
amongst many many Christians Catholics
Protestant Christians
um the value of symbolism has largely
been lost and there is a
over emphasis in my view on morals which
is something that can legitimately be
derived from religion
but morals are not the sum total of
religion there is much more to the
religious life than morals and symbolism
to me is crucial to that and and
Jonathan is sort of believing embodiment
of that attitude in the world that
frankly begun to be lost during the
Reformation already and the Reformation
was inspired by legitimate good and
important reasons but as almost
everything human beings do it sort of
careens out of control and throws the
baby out with the bath water and
religious symbolism iconic symbolism has
been lost even to the Catholic church
and today is kept alive only by the
Orthodox Churches across the world so
it's nice to see that
that vein in the human mind is still
nurtured and kept alive
thanks Verano and would you like to
phrase what you just described as a
question then Jonathan take over there
sure I mean
so maybe I can just so I've been
thinking a lot about the the problem of
we know we talked about the idea of for
example that the China like the angel of
China or something like that the idea
that there is some kind of agency there
are agencies which act above
us the above the human level and seem to
constrain us in our own agency let's say
as we act
um and this is something with John Vivek
we've been discussing a lot he tends to
be willing to use the word agency though
he really wants to avoid the word uh
Consciousness in those in in that
question
um and so that is really the what I'm
really curious to explore a little more
based on our discussion maybe I can
start with this uh so we talked I talked
about this idea of let's say the angel
of China let's use that word or the
principality of China and you were you
were diff you were bothered by the
notion of how is it that it exists let's
say
how is it that it exists outside of the
time that China exists in the world so
right does it have prior existence does
it continue to exist after after its its
existence
China that's the other question where do
you find the spatial boundaries well I
think that the the I was thinking about
that later and I was starting to wonder
if that's not the same problem from in
the in the case of humans as well right
this the idea that we have permeable
boundaries humans do as well both
mentally but then also physically our
physical boundaries because they're at
the level of our perception we see them
as more solid but they are they're
they're they're permeous and the same
would be for a higher being let's say a
city or a state it has you can still
locate it even physically in the world
you can locate it conceptually but it
does have permeability on its edges and
it seems to so you can't fix it that way
it's so like here I'm I'm really going
to be more like neoplatonic in the sense
that you can you can only fix it in its
higher aspect you can fix it in its
identity so it's actually its name
use the name used more in a more ancient
way that fixes it and then it's
manifestation or the the quantity of it
will always have permeability and change
so it's the ship of Theseus problem
right it's like is the ship of Theseus
still the ship of Theseus even though
its parts have been have changed have
been and my answer would be yes it is
because it's actually held together by
by name by memory by attention by all
these these mechanisms
before I comment on that can I ask you a
question inspired by something you said
if I don't ask the question now it will
be lost yeah sure sure go ahead you said
John viveki was comfortable using the
word agency
for higher levels of mentation but not
the word Consciousness do you know what
difference he makes in his mind between
the two and why this this distinction
well he seems to he seems to for well he
seems to think first of all that the
conscience is a very specific uh aspect
which has to do with
certain amount of speed and so speed of
connection is what would give rise let's
say to Consciousness I mean I don't
really agree with that myself but that
is that that is his main argument he
might he might say I'm not getting him
right so let's be careful here but this
is the understanding that I have of his
argument is that is that in the human
brain there is there's a certain amount
of speed of connection and
interconnectivity which can give rise to
a state of consciousness but that you
can't perceive that let's say at the
city level the connections are slow you
know like writing emails and writing
letters and and and uh you know people
talking amongst each other in order to
organize the the activities of the city
you would have a you'd have a slower
connection
um and so I don't to be honest I don't I
don't mind that I think that there are
just different types of consciousnesses
I don't mind the idea that that it would
be a slower Consciousness or just a
Consciousness that has a different
function than the human uh but that
that's that is the argument that I've
heard him make I think I understand I
think he's basing that on information
integration Theory
which I think applies to meta
Consciousness self-awareness by
metacognition not necessarily to
Consciousness in the phenomenal sense
pure experience so I think he is
probably conflating the two like a lot
of neuroscientists today conflate the
two but but I understand where it's
coming from I also don't agree because
when I talk about Consciousness I talk
about phenomenal Consciousness not
matter Consciousness but but I
understand the motivation now back to
your point
uh
what I would warn against Jonathan is
attributing private conscious in their
life to anything we have or can make up
a word for
because words are cheap uh what is China
Does it include Tibet and Hong Kong and
Macau or not and depending on the
decision you make here whether China
includes these three things or not does
it affect the ontological reality of
there being an angel of China or a
separate Angel for China and another one
for Hong Kong and another one from Macau
and another one for Tibet you see what I
mean
the same applies to a table in the case
of pen psychism if the pen psychist says
the table is conscious has a private
inner life of its own if I pull out one
of the feet of the table one of the four
legs do I create some kind of
dissociation and I create a new
conscious entity and thus that new
conscious entity emerges with the table
if I nail the leg back to the table or a
rock that detaches from a mountain does
it become separate from the mounting the
then in your life private in a life of
its own and does it reunite every time
it touches the mounting as it bounces
off the slope so we create a mass if we
if we see everything identifiable
through a noun through a word as an
agent as a conscious agent because you
know the way we apply words is arbitrary
the way we Define sets subsets and Sub
supersets in language is arbitrary it's
nominal as philosophers call it it's
done by convenience and doesn't
necessarily reflect any ontological
reality okay so there are two things I
would I would say to that or that it
would that made that I think when I hear
that one is I can apply again the same
the same problem to myself if I see
myself as a conscious agent I can ask
myself when I cut does my hair
participate in my conscious agency you
know do my fingernails what about if I
cut a finger off does the finger now you
know so I can ask the same question that
is why that I I tend to think that that
categories are captured in there in
their name game or in the place where
they come together rather than try to
find them contained in the place where
their multiplicity has a possibility of
of breaking apart let's say I see your
point but I think you miss
the one Criterion we have to define the
boundaries of us as as
individual agents with private conscious
in their life of their own and it's an
it's a Criterion that applies to us and
doesn't apply to objects doesn't apply
to the table to the mountain or to China
and it's the following if I pierce the
chair I'm sitting on with a needle I
don't feel it but if I pierce my arm I
do feel it yeah if a photon in my study
hits the wall behind me I don't see it
but if it hits my retina I do experience
it so that there is a objective
Criterion for defining the boundaries of
the human being and that is
what you register as an experience when
something interacts with it and what you
don't register as an experience when
something interacts with it now I
acknowledge that based on this Criterion
there is a question that is valid which
is are we the totality of ourselves or
are we only our nervous system because
it's only the nervous system that
registers you know that there there are
no nerve terminations in your hair
um so it's not part of you but then I
would say well there are no living cells
in your hair either it's just keratin
the same applies for your nails
um so I see that there is a question
there
um but I don't think it's a free-for-all
I don't think no I don't think it's a
free-for-all either for sure but in
terms of China for example I agree with
the table it's it's it but let's say if
you look at China the question that you
ask could be answered in terms of China
so in terms of boundary so you would say
so imagine there's China and then there
are a bunch of people that are that are
coming in and taking things like from
another state you know they at first
they they take refuse maybe they take
the trash on the side and when they do
that they don't hurt China and China it
doesn't matter doesn't doesn't care but
then at some point maybe they come in
and they start to take things or they
take part of the land or they they take
certain things that are that China
perceives as belonging to it and then
then China will react very much like a
pain reaction we'll send out soldiers
antibodies and will re will push away
the threat that it's that it is feeling
uh on itself and so if you see it that
way then at some point the the question
of Tibet or Macau or the or these are
these other identities would be
something like
you could you can imagine it like it's a
conflict of of identities it this is
what's happening there is a conflict of
an idea where China wants to extend its
body
to include these smaller identities and
those identities are resisting you can
almost imagine it like someone in the
forest hunting uh a deer and wants to to
to integrate the deer into himself
and the deer is resisting
my my street has a neighborhood watch
so if there is a strange person doing
funny things on my streets it will be
ejected by the nervous system of the
street
um does my street have an angel is there
an angel of the street where Bernardo
lives yeah I don't know these are the
questions that I'm asking questions like
to what like where how can we perceive
like to what because there are some for
example there are some theologians that
go all out with this they'll say as soon
as two people encounter themselves
there's a third being
there as soon as two people have a
conversation there's a third B
and and it's like that's I don't know
it's like I'm not sure I want to go
there but I'm just saying that these
these these problems have been thought
about in different ways to try to
account for the manner in which
in which there is a higher in which when
two people come together there's
something more than just the
accumulation of the two and we
experience it that's what a team is
right if you if you play on a team you
realize that there's an agency beyond my
individual agency or just the
accumulation of agency that seems to
manifest itself when we're dancing
together towards a common purpose
I think the Crux of the matter is what
one means by agency
um if agencies defined in such a way
that an agent has its own private
conscious in their life
um then I Think It's tricky to say that
there is a third agent when two people
talk because there is no evidence that
in addition to the private inner life of
the two there is a third private in a
life constituted of the combination of
the two can I disprove it no I cannot
but there are countless things one
cannot disprove and yet they don't
entertain because we have no reason to
entertain
um
I would caution against conflating
Concepts
with antique realities like an agent
with its own private conscious in their
life well this is not I don't think it's
concept so if we it's a if you notice
for example that you that conversations
you have with different people
have different flavors they they have
different implicit rules that sometimes
you can't even say like there's some you
act a certain way with your brother with
your your parents and then you act a
different way in different relationships
and there's a there's something which is
binding the the conversation which is
beyond
even each of our own Wills so so we
couldn't decide to make our relationship
something else than what it is there
there's a there's a kind of binding
let's say and that that that is a
there's a kind of agency that binds the
relationship in a direction
um and so that these are the things that
I'm I'm just trying to understand
because it's not it's not just Concepts
it's an experience even on our side like
to to be the member of a team and to be
playing basketball and going dribbling
down the the field and not having to
look and then passing the ball because
you know that the person is there and
they know that you're going to pass it
before you do and that and you've seen
it in a play and then people
exalt I mean when they see something
like that when someone sees multiplicity
joined together in a common goal in a
way that looks almost like it's it's one
body there's a joy that we experience we
experience that almost like as a kind of
ecstasy uh which explains the reason why
sport is so is so one of the reasons why
sport is so popular so those are the
types of behaviors that I'm trying to
figure out how they relate to
because they can be reduced to just I
don't think they can be
my allusion to Concepts was motivated by
the analogy you made between the army of
China and an immune system
um and why is that conceptual well
because it's an analogy made at a very
high level of conceptual abstraction
because there is no similarity at all
between the army of China and an immune
system if you think about them literally
you know what is an immune system and
what is the army of China they are
completely different things you do find
a valid similarity but to find it you
have to operate conceptually at a high
level of abstraction and then I warned
against
attributing private conscious in their
life to something to some similarity or
based on an analogy that operates on a
very high level of conceptual
abstraction because that may have
nothing to do with the actual reality of
the situation
regarding teen Dynamics I I'm totally
there with you that
something emerges weak emergence
something emerges when when
entities interact
and that emergence can be a very well
synchronized Dynamics across the members
of the team
um
I don't think that provides reason to
say that there is a higher level agent
that has a private conscious in their
life of its own just because of amazing
Team Dynamics or because of the way I
don't know Birds synchronize their
flight in the late afternoon
and even
um from the fact that your personal
inner life your inner experience changes
when you are involved in Dynamics
because look
every conscious agent always stands to
see something happen within itself once
it interacts with the outside world
including other conscious agents so
that's not a surprise we change
ourselves the moment we interact with
the not ourselves with the world out
there with others out there but I don't
see a logical reason why this should
imply that there is a higher level
conscious agent with a private conscious
in their life of its own that
corresponds to that basketball team or
to the Ant Hill there may be I think the
argument is stronger for the Ant Hill
actually than for the basketball team
but I I don't think
the suggestion
is strong I think we can account for all
that just based on System Dynamics
but look if I if I'm there is a thing
called cellular automata and computer
science one of them is called The Game
of Life it's a very very simple game
based on a matrix of cells yeah and
obeying two very simple rules only two
rules extremely simple if two or three
of your neighbors are alive then you are
alive if less or more then that cell
dies because it's overcrowded or doesn't
have companionship and then you program
a system like that and you set it off
based on these extremely simple rule
applied recursively to itself and you
see amazing Dynamics emerge and you see
guns that fire projectiles uh you know
you see populations of seemingly living
entities emerge but but we know that
that's the simple dynamics of applying a
simple rule recursively and we need
nothing further than that to explain
that amazing Collective Dynamics so yes
to me that's the the recursive the
recursive uh structure that is the one
that I'm attached to let's say that is
the notion that
the notion that let's say I am made up
of smaller
mentations if you want to if I'm going
to try to use your your try to come
close to the language you use it my idea
I recognize myself as one to a certain
extent and I see myself as one but I can
also notice in myself a multiple agents
in me that are sometimes fighting
towards with each other sometimes acting
in collaboration with each other and
when they act in collaboration with each
other then I experience more unity and
when they act against each other when
they fight with each other then I
experience disunity and it can get to a
form of Despair if it's too strong if
there's too strong a disunity among my
constituents then I can experience I can
experience despair
and so that and so what I noticed is
that that recur that recursive pattern
within me I can notice that I seem to be
participating in similar patterns above
me and I can't have like just as my as
from above I can perceive my mental
states fighting with each other I know
that those mental States can't perceive
me like they can't perceive the unity
that I experienced that that sees that
multiplicity and so in the same way I
noticed that I am participating uh in
the same type of fractal Behavior above
me in groups and and and and in and I
can see the same pattern where it is
that if members of a group collaborate
then we ex then there's more Unity
towards the purpose and if we don't
collaborate then there's more disunity
to a point where the group can die or
can can actually can actually fall apart
uh and so that is the thing that I'm
interested in and noticing the recursive
nature of this layered structure we
could say that move seems to move but
down below us but also seems to move up
above us
first just a very quick comment to to to
clarify what I meant by the term when I
when I said recursion applied to the
cellular automata what I meant was you
apply a rule to define the next state of
a cell
and then you apply the same rule to that
next state to generate the next state
and then you apply the same rule again
and so forth and I didn't mean fractal
self-similarity when I used the word
recursion
I sympathize with your intuition
um but I would say the following
The Logical logic question we have in
front of us when we sort of take this
intuition seriously and I have the same
intuition by the way uh so I I take it
very seriously
um the logic question is the following
are we talking about one mind that seems
to be many
or are we talking about many Minds that
somehow integrate to be one
or less
um I would suggest that the very fact
that you now can sit there and say I
notice myself being many
suggests very strongly that the
direction is top down and not the bottom
up it suggests very strongly that you
were always one mind and and that you
just seem to be many when there is
conflict across different mental
processes in yourself
well I see it I see it both ways this is
the way that I that I see it I see
there's a top-down
and then there's a bottom there's a
bottom-up aspect which seems to be
represented in different ways in in
different in at different scales but
let's say it's something like love this
is maybe the best word to use that that
there seems to be this notion that if we
love each other
then
then we actually are becoming you know
let's say I use Christian language
that if we love each other then we're
becoming the body of
the God man right could say it that way
but that but then it also is a top-down
process which is that you know he is the
head we are the body you know the the
the highest mind is also the cause of
the lower minds but so it's you can
experience it seems like you can
experience it in both ways so let's say
let's say if if the intuition of the
scaling
I know that
if I want my family to be one then it
I'm not going to experience it as a
top-down experience I'm going to
experience it as an effort to love my
wife and to love my kids
and ultimately it can be a top-down
reality like I can you can come to
realize that it is in some ways
higher a higher mind which is imposing
itself and that the the the conflict
that we had was uh with the Distortion
with an illusion once we've resolved it
um but I I definitely experience it top
bottom up when in my
in my behavior maybe is the best way to
say it towards these towards the
I don't know if that if that makes sense
it it does but I would suggest if only
the the experience that you're going
Bottom up is consistent with top down
being fundamental in the following way
if the apparent
um
fragmentation of Mind in this universe
you have your mind that have mine and
the amoeba in swimming my turret has its
mind and my cat has another mind
if that seeming diversity and separation
um is illusory because Illusions are
part and parts of experience so one mind
can have the illusion that it's many and
we know that that happens because people
suffer from dissociative identity
disorder which is now clinically
established as established as a fact and
they experience themselves in in exactly
that way they experience themselves as
being many because of the association
and yet they are not they are one mind
that has the illusion of being many you
experience that even without
pathological levels of dissociation when
you repress your memories repress your
emotions when you experience cognitive
dissonance
um now if that becomes the starting
State the illusion of Separation The
Illusion of being many
when some of that illusion is dissolved
then you come one step closer to the
reality of the matter
you will experience that as if it were a
bottom-up process well in fact it's not
it's a return
it's not going forward it's a going
backwards to where it all started so I I
think for sure I mean I think we agree
fundamentally not the Illusion part I
get to that but like fundamentally in
terms of
you know like to use Christian language
again we could say you know like Grace
Grace comes first without Grace
it has to come from above first
everything has to kind of flow from
above but
the love part the reason why I think
it's important is because love doesn't
annihilate the multiplicity Love
Actually preserves the multiplicity
and that's why I think it's such a
fundamental Concept in Christianity
which is that love will say something
like we can be both one
and many at the same time and so I can
both move towards unity and perceive the
multiplicity and see them as of course
not having an equal ontological State
the unity is superior to the
multiplicity but the multiplicity can
fully participate kind of indefinitely
as is this indefinite variation in
multiplicity in the the one and so I
find the language of Illusion
I tend to find the language of Illusion
uh more dangerous like in terms of in
terms of morality and what and the
implications of what that that means you
know you see that because because I it
seems like the notion that multiplicity
is illusory and that Unity is is the
only thing that's real the one mind is
the only thing that real seems to lead
to something at least in in the the the
ways of thinking that it brought this
about it seems to lead to something like
degradation in multiplicity where the
multiple is is is lesser in in almost in
a moral sense where you see that in the
caste system we see that in agnostic
cosmologies where creation is evil in
its in itself and love seems to be the
way that Christians tried to
to reconcile that with Greek inside you
need multiplicity together
I I didn't mean to pass any value
judgment on illusions at all I I used
the word in the you know in the very dry
technical analytic philosophical sense
which is when things seem to be
something other than what they in fact
are it's the seeming that is an illusion
but I didn't mean to pass value judgment
only Illusions meaning I don't see it as
good or as bad I see it as something
that happens it's one of the potentials
of Nature and it happens and the
usefulness of the idea is just to
distinguish between what seems to be and
what we have reason to think is actually
the case then we know that a person who
is suffering from dissociative identity
disorder only seems to be many because
that person can be cured can reintegrate
all of its alter personalities and
remember the memories of each one of
them and know that the person was one
hour long and it just seemed to be many
Now
using a pathology as an example may
suggest a value judgment because you
know pathology is bad so illusion is bad
and that's where my my metaphor went
wrong I didn't mean to pass on it at all
but there's also there's also I think
there's more at least in my vision
there's more than that because there's a
sense in which
so if there's so obviously I'm I'm
making a lot of leaps here but just
hopefully you can indulge me but let's
say we talk about this fractal system of
embedded beings you know in in each
other and that this is a reflection of
the one mind and this fractal
manifestation of how the one and the
many coexist in each other so we have
that sense there's a way in which
because when I see that in many of the
the thinkers that I admire I see that
for example C.S Lewis had some very
beautiful imagery to talk about that
where he would talk about how as you get
closer to the one the multiple becomes
more real it it actually it actually
um shines with more reality because it's
connected to the one and it's when it's
disconnected so you could say that about
the multiple personality person the
problem with the multiple personality
person is not that they have multiple
personalities you could say but it's
that those personalities don't know each
other and don't aren't United above but
if they're United above then you notice
that you do have within you
a multiplicity of desires and of thought
patterns and of directions
um and that you could something like
love all these multiplicities and give
them the reality they deserve let's say
in in the the human existence
I'm totally with you there okay um
sometimes I
speak of myself as many when I say that
I have a diamond and the diamond sets
you know the direction base and tone of
my life and that I've learned to not try
to resist that anymore to just apply
some kind of adult more of supervision
to the diamond because the diamond is a
force of Nature and it doesn't really
pass value judgments so I even speak of
myself as many and I'm totally with you
that to mature
not only as a person but even as an
entity in nature entails
um
giving space to the multiplicity within
us accepting the existence of all that
exists within us giving it its time
Under the Sun as opposed to trying to
slash it away to mutilate yourself or
repress or pretend that it's not there
um that doesn't work
um so I am with you there
um my pushback comes from
that
nuanced subtle and very tricky tricky
boundary when we cross from speaking
metaphorical language which is meant to
evote something evoke something in the
mind of another
and we cross it into some literal
statement
and Crossing that boundary can be tricky
because it may involve for instance in
my case saying that there is a actual
Diamond inside me that it's that is not
me and then it becomes a demon but a
diamond and it's a fundamentally
separate entity it sort of Tricks me
into doing its bidding then it goes
wrong that's where it goes wrong and and
I sense
that
if we are
too relaxed in terms of defining
entities
we cross that boundary and we start
projecting Angelic entities everywhere
in anything that we can use a word for
and conceptually distinguish from its
surroundings then the reason I find it
tricky Jonathan is the following
it's not limited to the discussion in
you you and I and I are having it it
sort of gives the tone to everybody's
World Views even in the west mainly in
the west which is the conflation
of nouns
with entities
we have nouns for all kinds of sub
entities that are part of the world the
world but these objects these sub
entities are carved out in a completely
nominal way in other words it's an
arbitrary separation an arbitrary inner
boundary within the totality that we
call existence for instance where does
the River end and the ocean begin
why do you say arbitrary it's a
functional it's a it's a purposeful
distinction one which fits our our
purposes as conscious uh age agents and
so it's like the dis the difference
between the river and the ocean is an
important distinction because you can
drink from the river you can't drink
from the ocean and therefore even though
there is a buffer of of of inter
interdeterminate the indeterminacy uh
those categories are nonetheless
they serve our Consciousness we could
say yes what I meant by arbitrary is
that it's nominal in other words it's
determined by convenience and use and
does not necessarily reflect a ontic
aspect of the world it doesn't
necessarily reflect the world as it is
in and of itself for instance
um
there is a subset of existence that we
call a car
and we say well the car ends here and
the surface of the tires and you know
whatever
um and if I ask you okay give me a clear
Criterion for criteria for determining
what is part of the car and what is not
because the car is made of components
and pieces that are just brought
together so are the spark plugs integral
to the car and you might say well yes
because without the spark plugs the car
doesn't function it doesn't move
and then I will latch onto that and say
okay then the engine is part of the car
yes the tire tires are part of the car
yes now let's go ahead
if there is no road for the tires to
grip the car doesn't move so the roads
are part of the car no no wait a moment
if there is no gravity to pull the tires
towards the road it doesn't grip either
and it doesn't move either so the
gravity needs to be part of the car
where does the gravity come from from
the total mass of the planet so the car
is everything it's the entire planet oh
actually not because the planet is what
it is because it rotates and skipped
within a stable orbit of spirent star
so the star the sun is part of the car
and I will go on and on and on and on
with this and never so that's why you
don't that but that's why you don't you
don't the boundary of the thing is not
in its physical quantities or in its
it's actually in its name or in its
purpose that's what that the the it's
the limit of the car appears in its Lim
in its name or in its purpose rather
than in its if you so but you could what
you're saying is true of everything like
anything that that you even your even
conscious agents like you know you can
stretch that either that you cannot find
a a fixed uh a fixed boundary between
things they are all permias there is one
exception to this every carving out of
existence is nominal I've stopped using
the word arbitrary it's nominal it's
done by convenience so it's epistemic
it's not ontological it reflects
our convenience and not the actual
states of Affair Affairs in the world
but there is one exception to this and I
already mentioned that the boundaries of
us as entities are objectively
determinable because if I stick a needle
in my chair I don't feel it but if I
stick a needle on my skin I do feel it
it's the only thing the boundaries of
living Minds
as determined by what they can
experience and what they can't
everything else carving out the
inanimate Universe into objects is
nominal it's done by convenience and
therefore
I don't think it's logical for us to say
well something I carved out merely by
convenience has a private inner life of
its own why because it it's akin to
taking an abstract painting and saying I
will nominally determine that the subset
of all reddish pixels on this painting
are a thing yeah and now there is an
angel for the reddish pixels on on the
canvas why that carving out was
completely based on convenience or taste
or whatever it doesn't necessarily
reflect the states of Affair beyond your
own mind that's what I was warning
against no I I attributing a conscious
agency to everything we create a word
for yeah well one of the ways one of the
ways that I it seems this is something
I've been thinking about recently and
and some people watching this are really
going to struggle with what I'm gonna
say but that's fine we'll say it anyways
so there's a there's a sense in which in
the in the Bible there's a figure that
appears the son of man right you see
this figure appear in the Book of Daniel
you also see it appear but not named in
the in the Book of Ezekiel in the Divine
Vision where there's the shape of a man
on the on the Divine Chariot
um
and Philo of Alexandria develops this
idea of Adam Cadman or Universal manner
Heavenly Man different ways to talk
about it of course in Christianity we
have the sense in which Christ is that
incarnation of The Heavenly Man but even
if you don't believe in Jesus Christ you
don't even need that yet in order to
understand the notion of positing man at
the right hand of God
ruling over the angels and and the sense
would be that
that there's a manner in which I think
we talked about it this last time which
is that all perception of of agency in
the world is reflected through human
agency so it's actually mirrored through
the human the human that we can perceive
images of agency in the world both below
us you know or on the same level but
also above us so the image for example
that you know the image that the son of
man rules over the Angels the son of man
is above the angels and and the sense
would be that the Angels serve man you
see you hear that in Christian theology
but that could have a more technical
meaning which is the notion that
the the perceptions of agency that we
have are the cohesion that we see in the
world actually are
in the service of man that is they they
are they are real to the extent that
they serve
human in the with the man with the big M
you know the mat the the the the man
with the big M um so that is for me at
least it's been a way that I've been
trying to think about the problem so if
you think about a team for example right
so higher agencies like China or all
these other higher beings that seem to
have some kind of agency over us that if
we have the notion that they ultimately
should serve man with a capital M then
they it seems to make more sense that
although they have agency over us
ultimately they are mirrored through our
Consciousness as something which is
there for us because basketball is there
not for you know it's there for us it's
it's it has it has a human yeah anyways
I don't know if what do you think about
it no no I'm totally with you now I
converge fully with you
um
it is
insofar as it helps us in some way even
if they're not metacognitive way
to
project agency
onto the world
according to delineations that serve our
purposes best
I think it's perfectly all right to do
that I would call it a metaphorical
carving out of the world and I do that
with myself even it it helps me
regard my own mind as a multiplicity and
talk of Talk of the diamond
the diamond reflects
its usefulness to me I create the
diamond by looking at myself with those
lenses
so in that sense I'm playing the role of
the son of man and I determine what are
the Angelic entities Within Me based on
what will bring me forward in the most
productive teleological you know
morally positive way I'm totally with
you there
um
and so could you perceive that this
would so so the idea would be the way
that I see it would be that that could
also go awry that process
so it could also become uh parasitic
where oh yeah where where where you know
we have we have we project if you want
to we use that term or there are angels
that are supposed to serve us and that
have that hold beings together that have
agency over us that become that become
Twisted because they were they were
created with with with with uh parasitic
desires or whatever it is or these
multiple personalities that were were
acting at a higher level so I think
about like Facebook for me is the great
example of that you know where it's like
we we create this thing
and then the person the people who
created it did not understand the they
didn't do it in wisdom you could say
they didn't understand the side effects
of the being they were unleashing on the
world and so now Facebook has agency
over people it actually it actually
manages the way that they pay attention
the way that they communicate the way
that they come into relationship with
each other and now all the side effects
of that are starting to show themselves
and you know in hyper politicized groups
and all these types of things that
everybody's been complaining about
Facebook for for years now but that you
can see the process of
the the process of a of a good angel
that would manage our Behavior together
going awry and becoming parasitic let's
say
yeah I I think we don't even need to go
to Facebook we can stay within the
universe of our own mind
um I think anybody who pays attention
and has paid attention for a while in
their adult life
knows that demons are real not real in
the literal sense in the sense that my
demons would still be here and exist
even if I were not around no that that
crosses the line to literal territory
and I think that not only
is wrong literally but it flattens the
message of you know of the metaphorical
world too much
um but if I don't cross that line
that there are demons within me it's a
it's an obvious fact of existence there
are the Demons of addiction within me
that are insatiable and will eat myself
alive if there aren't the angels of
teleology and meaning that keep them in
check
um
[Music]
you could describe
almost the entire depth and richness of
human conscious life
with the language of angels and demons
and and I think therein lies the
profound truth of religious language
um but I would I would push back a
little bit on saying that they don't
exist outside me and the reason why I
would say that is because because I can
gain insight about my demons from others
and so I can re I recognize that other
people are dealing with the same demon
that I'm dealing with it's although its
manifestation is purely individual right
it you could you could say that if if
there's this fractal if there's this
fractal structure let's say that there's
a there's an anal there's an analogous
aspect in me a passion this is the way
that the church rathers talk about it
there's a passion in me that's out of
control and that passion corresponds to
something which is transpersonal this
transpersonal thing will hook on to that
and then we'll run like a program in you
and we'll we'll let's say we'll run this
parasitic program inside you and so so I
if I I can read a church father from the
5th Century and that church father can
help me deal with my a demon because
they had to deal with the same
the same demon let's say
I will agree with you even there
um the distinction is how we use the
word I right because you said well there
are things outside meme what is the mean
um I think if we call the eye our core
subjectivity
I think there is nothing outside that
because the course of objectivity me is
the same as that in you and it's the
core subjectivity of the Divinity itself
it's it's that field of transpersonal
subjectivity that underlies all nature
nothing exists outside of it so all
Angels and Demons exist there and they
are outside my ego
um my angels and demons are certainly
outside my ego and that's why it's
useful
for the ego to talk of them as external
entities but I don't think they are
outside my core subjectivity right so if
you understand the fact that like when
you would say some like the fact that
you are connected to the ground of being
at the core of who you are like the
Divine spark or Christ in you or you
know different ways of expressing it in
Tradition that that at the very core of
you is the same right is the is that is
that one yeah yeah that one ground I'd
say yeah and that's why there is a sense
even though you may not like that sense
because of the use of words but that's
why there is a sense
in which
um
I lost my train of thought now but
there is a sense in which Unity is
fundamental and not diversity because
all diversity unfolds within that one
course objectivity
that's what I meant when I said that
multiplicity is ultimately an illusion
which is not to say that there aren't
levels in the hierarchy of being where
those Illusions are very real it still
has Illusions but very real for every
conceivable practical purpose
yeah well for sure for sure in in
Christian theology they try to make put
multiplicity right at the highest
right there right you know the Trinity
is is the the really the expression of
the multiplicity at the at the very core
and that that one in many are the very
principle by which all things exist like
there that this loving relationship
between the one and the many is that the
mode of being of all things and in that
context are there transpersonal Angels
and Demons
based on my own inner experience I would
say yes there are I personally have very
little doubt about it if any I see three
levels of identity one is the ego
that narrative we think of us as being
that narrative that little person born
on that date married to that other
person who has this job and so forth
that's the ego that's the first level
the next level is what is yours
personally but it's beyond the ego in
jungian terminology the personal
unconscious
it's all your of your repressed stuff uh
your the stuff that you don't
acknowledge about yourself the memories
that you're not recalling
um it's still you as an individual mind
but it's well beyond your ego and it's
much much much bigger than the ego but
it's still you as an individual agent
and then there is a transpersonal which
in Union terminology would be the
collective unconscious which is still
psychic it's still mental it's still
phenomenally conscious it's just not
meta-conscious
um and there are psychic processes there
psychic complexes
um that young called the diamonds
um that may not have a physical
correlate
which Evolution did not have a
motivation to creating as a perceptual
apparatus capable of picking those
entities out because they may not have a
direct bearing on our ability to survive
may not pose a direct physical threat to
us so we didn't evolve the sense organs
or the the perceptual apparatus to pick
them out but they may still be out there
in that in that
ocean of Mind of which we are apart and
within which we are immersed as
individual agencies and they may impinge
on us they may not have a direct bearing
on our ability to survive but they most
definitely have a direct bearing in our
ability to be happy or be depressed or
be sad
or engage in addictive patterns of
behavior of being capable of developing
a certain degree of self-insight do I
believe they are there I think well
speaking as an analytic philosopher
under the premises of analytic idealism
I would say it's a virtual statistical
certainty that they are out there
because what are the chances that we
would have developed the perceptual
apparatus that is required to pick out
everything around zero that's not how
Evolution works that that's not that's
not how stuff works so there are
semi-autonomous psychic complexes up
there which you could call
individuated agents to some extent still
part of this single course objectivity
ultimately still part of the one but
behaving as a distinct aspect of
whatever is going on that have subtle
bearing on on our conscious in their
lives sometimes even less than subtle
bearing on our conscious in their lives
there are there is a tune called the
collective shadow
which can grip an entire country an
entire civilization
um and on the other hand
there are the archangels that can grip
entire countries and entire
civilizations as well and they are not
us as individuals they are not us as
egos even less
but they are in us as
core subjects core subjectivity
um so from that perspective I think
Unity is fundamental
but in practice diversity
is what life is about
I know Marcus if if you want to pipe in
if you have something that you're that
this is making you think about
so one of the things that's coming
across to me is
the once we reach the limits of language
as it were that we arrive at the series
of paradoxes and
um I got the same impression whenever
you were speaking with John verbaki that
the nature of reality LED suffered as a
skin narrative pattern but also this
known logical and collapse it into one
is damaging and then um
sort of wanted to ask Bernardo a bit
about this as a scientist too
the science itself even
a point Beyond itself in this kind of
paradoxical way with things like
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle or
goodells and complete theorem things
like that and read in somebody like
mcgilchrist's work
it's the work that he seems to do on the
brain even seems to suggest this where
he's using the best science to point
Beyond science and he ends up resorting
to things like music to conveys deepest
Reflections does that make sense and
um I wonder what you would think about
that
in philosophy
um there is a serious and significant
school of thought that puts forward the
notion that true paradoxes exist
and they can be as trivial as language
paradoxes such as the following
statement
this statement is false
this is a true Paradox because if this
statement is true then it is false but
it is false then it's true
so this statement is either both or
neither and the law of excluded middle
one of the five axioms of Aristotelian
logic is out the window something as
trivial as a phrase this statement is
false is a true contradiction from that
sense
um
but it is a contradiction only under the
axioms of Aristotelian logic
and namely the law of excluded middle
the notion that something is either true
or false never both and never neither
um but as every Axiom of logic this too
is a fundamentally arbitrary Axiom we
adopt the axioms because they seem to us
to be self-evidently true but you cannot
logically argue for the validity of
logic without incurring circular
reasoning or begging the question
so I I take this notion seriously having
said that I think abuse to science
is proving that there are true
contradictions in the world world
are misleading at the best and probably
flat out fallacious for instance this
notion that um
particles can be waves or can be uh
particles at the same time is based on a
fundamental misunderstanding of quantum
theory
there is no such a thing as particles
being waves and being particles at the
same time the waves in question are
models of probability distribution
the particle itself isn't a wave and
isn't a particle either what we are
talking about is the probability
distributions of making certain
measurements and if you truly understand
that
then wave particle duality is not an
instance of a true contradiction in the
word in the world at all that that's
based on very superficial
misunderstanding of the science involved
so and that's a Pity that people do that
because they don't need this
misrepresentations and misunderstandings
to make a strong case that Aristotelian
logic has brought us so far but cannot
bring us further that we need to revise
our basic axioms of logically logic
particularly the law of excluded middle
and get rid of it like a Dutch
philosopher called lautson Brower
proposed in the very early 20th century
get rid of that Axiom because it leads
to
ridiculous situations for instance let
me give you an example because we think
that everything is either true or false
never both and never neither
I can prove that a completely unknown
and undefined thing exists
even though I have never seen it even
though I can't even describe it I can't
say what it is but I can prove that it
exists by proving that it cannot not
exist
now that's insane that's ridiculous
that's taking our epistemology and
projecting it onto the world as ontology
it doesn't work to prove that something
exists at the very minimum you have to
describe precisely what it is that
you're saying that exists
but the law of excluded middle if it's
taken into our axioms
allows for something that I don't even
describe
to be proven to exist which is
nonsensical
so I I'm all for revising our logic and
maybe adopting intuitionistic logic
which is the technical term for for the
logic proposed by lauten Brower but I
think it's fallacious to say that
quantum mechanics proves that the world
is illogical no it I think that's based
on
misunderstanding of quantum theory
um and um what is your view on is it
Giga renser and people like that and his
notion of unconscious intelligence
Bernardo have you come across much by
him that kind of
um
Russian rationality Beyond racialism
which seems to suggest that for well one
humans are not primarily rational and
that's kind of smaller sense but also
that we are in Canary study impressions
as if they could be reliably and
rationally
um predicted I think that we can easily
break patterns but different populations
produce different candidate results and
tests very economic professors and
things like that because Austin or
choices are so hard to predict in part
and multifaceted if we have this kind of
say economic system built on these prior
myths that were primarily rational in
that criter sense and free choosing
agents so then as long as we maintain
that bias will we see these more
impoverished results and misleading
metrics then and I'm interested in Harry
that um that's built into our
institutions and do you see any examples
that concern New Year I'd prefer to call
it spontaneous intelligence as opposed
to unconscious intelligence
when people refer to it as unconscious
intelligence they are implicitly
defining Consciousness as
meta-consciousness
in other words the ability not only to
experience but to know that you are
experiencing that's meta Consciousness
and the denial of that people call
Loosely unconsciousness well in fact
it's just
a spontaneous intelligence is when you
take
several steps in your line of thinking
that you are not explicitly aware of
taking but those steps steps are still
conscious
you just don't know that you are
experiencing them but you are
experiencing them if you know what I
mean so you could call these
um this form of reasoning um spontaneous
intelligence which is a form of
intelligence that unfolds without being
um under the microscope of explicit
introspection
um I do I believe this exists absolutely
and the proof of it is the universe the
universe is the product of the
spontaneous intelligence of nature can
start talking about the fine tuning and
all that stuff although I find that
stuff disconcerting and probably human
projection is involved here but even if
the order of the universe is a human
projection and there is a very strong
case to be made that it is and I
personally believe that it is but even
if it is that
then then it's a projection of
spontaneous human intelligence because
we don't catch ourselves constructing
the order of the universe if you know
what I mean uh it's just there
um once I made an experiment
I
decided to I am I'm amateur chess player
and no no I don't play in tournaments or
anything I just have fun playing chess
and I don't want to ever go beyond that
but once I decided to do an experiment
um and play chess without what chess
players call calculations which is
the difference is the following
sometimes you look at a position on the
board and something in you knows how you
should go forward what your next move
should be what you should try to do but
you don't know why you know that you
don't know why you think that this is
the right move and what you do is you
start calculating you start playing out
the moves in the imaginary board inside
your head often you will catch chess
players like this they are not napping
it's just that they are calculating 20
moves ahead and if they're watching the
board in front of them it disturbs those
calculations because they are seeing
pieces not moving while they have to see
the pieces moving now and the board the
physical board keeps on bringing them
back to that position doesn't let them
calculate or you often see chess players
doing like this
Nakamura which is an American chess
player he's often like this and you're
like what does he see in the ceiling no
he sees the chess board 20 moves ahead
that's calculating I decided to play
three chess matches without calculating
just following my intuition
and the results were well above my
yellow rating I had a much higher score
than normal and then I started believing
in this and I played the fourth game
totally spontaneous and I lost miserably
[Music]
and what what I'm trying to say by this
is the following spontaneous
intelligence definitely exists it's
definitely very powerful
but if you indulge in it's too much you
can step on mines it can go wrong so the
ideal situation is how to find a balance
between explicit intelligence in which
you take your steps of reasoning
explicitly and you cross check them and
the holistic approach of
spontaneous intelligence which is not
focused on discrete steps but focused on
seeing the whole pattern at once finding
that balance is is the key to being
successful in many aspects of life not
only at playing chess
no I I think I'm I really I I find it
very interesting what you're talking
about because you can find examples you
find types of people too types of people
that have followed that spontaneous
you know and for example the franciscans
for a short part of their existence they
would get up in the morning they would
just turn on their on themselves and
then whatever Direction they would stop
they would just go in that direction and
then and then they would just think you
know without food without anything and
just encounter whatever it is that they
encountered you know
um and so like Ronaldo said it probably
led to some great things but it also led
to some pretty
some darker like moments like because I
know people like that they they in
Christian terms people say something
like we follow the Holy Spirit like the
Holy Spirit guides us this kind of
intuition that they sometimes it goes
great and sometimes it goes horribly
like just worse than any I mean it's
like if you get up in the very worst
place uh so so I kind of understand that
uh can I make a quick comment on that
channel just yeah just to make sure that
people understand my position I don't
think the Holy Spirit ever gets it wrong
no I know of course not no I agree but
you know people just go with their no no
no without
that's the point yeah when it goes wrong
it's not the spontaneous intelligence of
nature that failed it's when we take
ourselves to be the subtle intelligence
of nature yeah you see what I mean yeah
it's a very very subtle State of Mind to
be in tune with the subtle intelligence
of nature that underlies us and
everything else
and believe your own [ __ ] yeah so
don't you think though in in case of in
K in terms of the chest that that the
training that you gave yourself let's
say for many years I imagine playing
chess is also the proper body in which
to maybe let that intuition go because
if you just get someone who's played
chess once in their life and say yeah
just just follow your intuition they
might not make it very far like there's
there's as if there's any you have to I
mean imagine like a a sports player too
you you play your ten thousand hours or
whatever and then at some point you stop
thinking you just act because it's so
integrated in you that it's almost
leading itself into into realizations I
get that when I'm carving now when I'm
carving carving for so long that I I
just just go and I don't and I I just
experience this this flow of movement
where I don't have to think about what
I'm doing it just happens
I think in practice you're you're right
training is what allows us to sort of
synthesize to that frequency that
carrier wave of subtle intelligence in
nature if you're not trained you can't
connect to it but um
I think
and now I will go now our roles will be
reversed stop being the analytic
philosopher now I think
we
are lying on top
of a vein of subtle intelligence that is
not ours at all and it doesn't depend on
training at all
um it's just very very it's
extraordinarily difficult one to
synchronize with it you know to to
resonate with it and two once you do
resonate to distinguish that resonance
from your own [ __ ] like my fourth
game of chess I thought oh I can win
everything if I don't think I'll just
play the first move that comes to my
mind and boom then I lost because I
mistook my own [ __ ] for the subtle
spontaneous intelligence of nature but I
I will tell you another part of the
story that I was not planning to tell
and I don't know how you're going to
judge it but several years ago
as a philosopher of mine I thought that
it would be an accept unacceptable for
me to talk about mind and Consciousness
without studying my own mind and
Consciousness in every way available and
one way available in my country where
it's legal is to use psychedelics
there was another time in which I played
those games of Chess
during the re-entry of a psychedelic
trip
and I don't know whether you have ever
taken psychedelics you probably don't
need if you leave a symbolic symbolic
life you probably don't need there I
have I had a very very hard mind so I I
needed to take a hammer to it to sort of
open myself up to certain things so I
did in need it has been used for it's a
phase of my life that is behind me now I
don't feel
compelled to do it again but at the time
I did it has been very helpful but one
thing you anybody who has done
psychedelics know is that um during the
re-entry when you're sort of beginning
to reconstitute your daily self your
mind sort of reconstituting its
narratives reconstituting its cognitive
associations that web of associations
that gives it a sense of personal
identity
during that transition
you there's no way other way of putting
this you can't think straight
you're very open as if you weren't
dreaming when you're not thinking
straight uh your the imagery of a dream
unfolds spontaneously and that
characterizes that phase of a trip when
you begin to come back you can take
certain decisions
um there there is a sober part of your
mind standing behind you but you can't
think logically in other words you you
can't calculate in a game of chance and
I played games of Chess in that state
and I won all of them
and if you ask me was that based on my
training no because that that mind
standing behind me was saying to me I
have absolutely no idea why I want to
play this move
no idea whatsoever it looks like a
completely absurd move to me why am I
doing this now 15 moves later to be
clear why I absolutely needed to play
that move and I knew it
um was that because of training no I
think it was a very very difficult
subtle
State of Mind in which you plug in to a
collective stream
of spontaneous intelligence in the mind
of Nature and if you plug into that for
briefly before your ego reasserts itself
and
mistakes it for its own [ __ ] that
brief window of time
uh you you you are manifesting
spontaneous intelligence that has
absolutely nothing to do with your
training look at that let me be more
objective now there are people who
suffer from so-called acquired Savant
syndrome
um in which you suffer head trauma
damage to your brain ordinary brain
function is no impact it's damaged and
they become Geniuses like they can do
enormous mathematical calculations
instantly as fast as a computer
and if people ask them how did you know
the result they they will invariably say
I don't know it just came to me I looked
at it and I knew the answer they don't
take explicit metacognitive steps of
reasoning to arrive at the solution to a
mathematical problem you just do it and
and that is a possibility that's a
capability that is unlocked by damage
brain damage lightning strikes to the
Head uh uh head trauma from car
accidents even the progression of
dementia can unlock a quiet Savon so how
do you make sense of that I would say
the only way to make sense of that is
that damage is so specific
they got so lucky in the kind of damage
they suffered that instead of the damage
impairing their normal metacognitive
intelligence or in addition to impairing
their normal metacognitive intelligence
it unlocked a part of the human mind
that blocks out the spontaneous
intelligence of nature
in order to benefit a metacognitive
intelligence in other words uh
deliberate reasoning deliberate thinking
deliberate decision making which
probably had all kinds of evolutionary
advantages because it's based on the
notion of an individual self that needs
to survive and and that somehow
obfuscates the spontaneous intelligence
of nature that is always at at the
the foundational level of ourselves and
the whole of nature and and when that is
unlocked by of all things trauma damage
then you see through spontaneous
intelligence at work that has nothing to
do with training required Savant didn't
train yeah didn't Train musical
composition they didn't train
mathematics they didn't train any of
that
yeah no I I've seen the examples that
this was one guy who all of a sudden
could see he saw geometric shapes
everywhere like you could see extremely
complex geometric patterns underlying
reality and would draw them just
freehand they've got these complex
geometric patterns so I know I I
seems like you're there's something
there for sure I I have a question for
you because it's something that I've
heard you talk about and I hear you you
brought it back again in this
conversation which is let's say the
difference between cognition and
metacognition
and let's say the fact that we are meta
conscious or self-conscious do you
perceive or do you do you think that
there are other beings that are that
have that
that characteristic or do you think that
at least at least as you know only
humans are self-conscious
I think to the degree that humans are
self-conscious or metacognitive only
humans are I think there are and there's
enough evidence to very seriously
contemplate the possibility that
cetaceans and pachytherms and perhaps
some other higher primates primates are
to some extent matter conscious but not
to the extent that we are and the reason
I say this is the following
in the evolution of meta-consciousness
there is a point in which you cross over
a crucial boundary and that's the
boundary of instinct
um when you become extremely
meta-conscious you stop listening to
Instinct you stop listening to the
spontaneous intelligence of nature
um and you will listen only to your
deliberate planning your deliberate
action taking and that unplugs us from
the web of instinct that keeps nature
balanced and that's why we risk
destroying the planet in ourselves while
destroying the ecosystems of the planet
we'll never destroy the planet give it a
million years and it will be full of
trees and animals again but we would
destroy the present ecosystem why
because we have become alienated from
the ebb and flow of instinct given our
extremely high level of metacognition
and even if cetaceans and pachyderms
have a degree of metacognition it
clearly has not yet been enough to
unplug them from instinct
otherwise they would be Building
Technology by now
okay and so so I imagine that when you
look at the story of the fall of Adam
and Eve you see that in that story which
is the shift between cognition and
metacognition and the the knowledge of
Good and Evil let's say yeah that's when
we were expelled from the garden what a
beautiful metaphor for when you are
expelled from the web of instinct
um I mean the the story in Genesis
it raises the hairs in my body when I
think about that story because the level
of insight in that story if you have the
eyes to read it and you don't cartoonize
it by taking it literally the the depth
of insight there is is amazing and when
you think sorry if I go on a tirade stop
me if if I shouldn't but when you when
you think
um of how long it took us
to see the truth in that story and how
much effort it took us it it raises the
question how did the Jews exiled in in
Babylon two and a half thousand years
ago come up with that stuff how on Earth
could they
I mean it it's astounding only very
recently uh when we've discovered that
uh
the rise of symbolic thinking
in humans occurred only Thirty to fifty
thousand years ago
about 150 000 maybe 250 000 after
whatever genetic mutations happened that
made us anatomically modern humans
we have existed as an anatomically more
than humans in you know biologically
modern humans for two to three hundred
thousand years but only Thirty to fifty
thousand years ago did we begin to think
symbolically in other words did we
develop metacognition which is
astounding because whatever mutation has
led to our unique ability to think
symbolically
happened and was fixed in the genome
thousands of years before it was of any
use
how on Earth this contradicts evolution
in a certain way and there is a famous
guy Ian tattersall the curator of the
American history of the American Museum
of Natural History he is on record
saying in his book masters of the planet
he's saying the only reason we have to
believe that such a thing the fall that
such a thing could ever possibly have
happened is that it did happen otherwise
it would be reasonable it's beyond
implausible it's downright ridiculous
that it could happen
and and the Jews excited in Barcelona in
Babylon
knew it two and a half thousand years
ago that that boggles my mind I don't
know about yours but you know I I just I
become disorientated with it yeah well I
mean
because you see for according to the to
Genesis we didn't fall into Humanity we
felt as humans that's an important
differentiation which is now what we
know scientifically was the case sorry
sorry to interrupt you no no no no
that's fine I uh
so so this is I mean this is really
where my question is leading to this
this problem because I've shown you even
now you were talking about the
unconsciousness and you're talking about
say the ground of being or the ground of
subjectivity as being an unconscious and
so
you seem to be you seem to not like the
idea that meta consciousness
is so let me rephrase this so there's a
sense in which you see this in the
mystical fathers you see this in San
Ephraim and and several of the church
fathers where they talk about how the
fruit of the knowledge of Good and Evil
the reason why it made us fall was
because we were not ready for it and
that it is ultimately a blessing but
it's a blessing that had to be prepared
you could say and so either either Adam
and Eve would have sometimes Adam and
Eve represented as children you see that
in Saint irenaeus for example and that
that this fall is necessary for their
it's like an educational process in
which they will then come back up on the
other side as having integrated both the
consciousness of Good and Evil and the
garden and the image of that of course
is something like the Heavenly Jerusalem
we see that at the end of the Bible
um and so
there's a sense in which at least in
this type of vision that conscious meta
Consciousness is what brings about the
fall but is ultimately which actually
makes us similar to God and and because
I've heard you talk about God more as
this kind of unconscious or basic
Consciousness that doesn't have
metacognition so I was wondering if what
your thought is on that which is that at
least in the Christian understanding and
I think in many other religious
understandings the idea that God is
unconscious or is just this this very
very basic form of conscience that
doesn't have meta consciousness
seems to imply that meta Consciousness
is is a degrading from that or that it's
a fall again that it's only a fall or
that it's it's a it's a
that it's a less it's less than what
where it comes from
well there's a lot sorry in fact there
Jonathan
um
go back to to my true story and how I
played chess extremely well while
lacking meta Consciousness because I was
under the effect of drugs
um if you regard it from that
perspective meta Consciousness was
limiting because a limited but
deliberate form of intelligence
meta-conscious intelligence
obfuscated a spontaneous much broader
but less reliable form of intelligence
in other words the spontaneous
intelligence of nature
but the guy who won those games was the
spontaneous intelligence of nature Yeah
unobfuscated by my explicit deliberate
reasoning
from that perspective
it is a step backwards because it
contracts intelligence
um
but whatever stays within the field of
metacognition which is a contracted
field vastly contracted field it's like
looking down a microscope you only see a
tiny part of the world
but that tiny part now is visible
so you are
as far as that tiny part is concerned
it's better you see it more clearly
it's like looking down the microscope
you see one square millimeters but you
see it more clearly it is better
but it's worse in the sense that you
don't see anything around it anymore
and to me that's meta Consciousness and
that's why meta Consciousness was
favored by Evolution because as far as
survival is concerned you only need to
look at the tiny subset of existence
that is in your immediate surroundings
because that's what has a direct
immediate bearing on your survival and
your ability to reproduce So Meta
Consciousness is like a microscope it
blinds you to nearly everything
but it makes you see much more clearly
whatever remains within its field it
obfuscates everything else but it
amplifies what it focuses on so it's
both a step
forward and a step backward now in the
Bible
it's written that the serpent tells Eve
that after she takes a bite from the
fruit of the tree of knowledge she will
be like God now you may interpret that
as God being meta conscious but I
interpret it differently and I'll show
you with you my own interpretation the
key characteristic of the deity is the
ability to create realities
that's that ultimately is the single
most defining feature of the Divine mind
is the ability to create realities
a non-metacognitive mind cannot create
realities because it's always in the
present that's the eastern advaita and
Buddhist approaches you're always in the
present in other words you're always in
the world created for you by the
divinity
but when you metacognize and you
identify yourself as a subject of your
experiences as opposed to the
experiences themselves metacognition is
what allows you to say I have hunger as
opposed to I am the hunger if you're
always in the present you are the hunger
body you don't have hunger you are the
hunger You Are The World created for you
but when you become metacognitive you
invent Futures and you manipulate pasts
you create worlds you create realities
and I think it is in that sense
that Eve would become like God having
taken a bite from the fruit of
metacognition
and that is a fall in in the same way
that looking down a microscope is a fall
it's a contraction it obfuscates
everything else you become blind to
everything
but it is a step forward in the sense
that it allows you to see that tiny
subset more clearly
so have you ever thought about creation
that way which is that if you read the
creation account in Genesis
you have at the outset you have you know
heaven and earth the earth is chaos and
void emptiness and void and then God
creates names at the outset and if you
see the way it works is that God says
let there be light
and then God sees and God says it is
good it is good right and so there is
that narrowing it seems like that
narrowing is actually part of the the
separation of phenomena itself because
the the the the the the the
UN completely un
bridled potential or just like you know
the the UN un anything that has no
identity yet that is completely just
potential is not in you can't inhabit
that like even when you took your
psychedelics you didn't
if you if you had well you I mean
imagine that some people say they do
reach that point of complete you know
but then you would you couldn't stay
like that for you we couldn't stay there
for very long right because you would
probably just die of hunger at some
point or you would you wouldn't but
there has to be this Focus where there's
a contraction and uh pointing and then a
recognizing of the good so so that's why
I that's why I mean I really like the
idea that you're saying that there's a
sense in which
meta Consciousness is part of the
creation of Worlds I seem I think I see
that in the in the Genesis creation
narrative itself
I will agree with you
I'm not going to interpret evidence
differently just to fit my narrative so
I will agree with you that that part of
Genesis where God passes value judgments
on his creation
um is an indication a indication of
metacognition because value judgments
can only be passed through metacognition
that's why animals are amoral they are
not metacognizant so they can't pass
value judgments they they carry no moral
responsibility we do
and the Bible does suggest that the
creation the Creator Divinity
was not a conscious in so far as it
could could pass value judgment
um so I'll give you two answers
based on pure a purely analytic approach
in Natural Sciences and no empirical
evidence rational thinking
I would say we have every reason to
believe that the broader mind of nature
mind at large is not matter conscious
why because meta-consciousness seems to
have been something that evolved at
Great cost through eons of evolution by
natural selection
it seems to be an ability that forms in
response to a challenging environment
and an environment that requires
appropriate And Timely
responses to environmental challenges
and and therefore that narrowing of
metacognition that allows for a more
efficient localized narrow but much more
efficient and clear response was favored
by natural selection so if meta
Consciousness is something that evolved
then it was not there in the beginning
and the Divine mind or the mind of
nature that especially Unbound field of
subjectivity that underlies all nature
did not have to put up with the
challenges of a local ecosystem so it
wouldn't have meta-consciousness another
reason is we don't seem to see Meta
Consciousness in the simpler forms of
life on this planet the evolutionarily
speaking earlier forms of life there is
a clear correlation between more evolved
species and increasing meta
Consciousness Pachyderm cetaceans and
higher primates primates are highly
evolved species if you look at
paramecium or paramecia which are
single-celled organisms that go after
food and run away from danger even
though they don't have a nervous system
they react instinctively crocodiles are
very instinctual creatures you can tell
precisely how many inches you have to be
close to a crocodile before it tries to
laundry and new it's not a deliberating
Meta Meta Consciousness so from an
analytic and empirical perspective I
would say you we have every reason to
think that meta Consciousness is evolved
and it's not there from the beginning
it's not in the mind of nature it's not
in the mind of God which doesn't mean
that nature isn't intelligent
because spontaneous intelligent isn't
metacognitive
and spontaneous intelligence although
doesn't amplify things it has a very
Broad View it's the telescope as opposed
to the microscope
it doesn't discern the microscopic
details but it sees a lot more
now
if I ignore
analytic philosophy and Natural Sciences
and we speak purely from religious
scripture and religious insight
then I would have to acknowledge that
there are plenty of suggestions
throughout the religious traditions of
this world this world that the Creator
Divinity even if it's not the ultimate
Divinity like in gnosticism the Creator
Divinity was meta-conscious that seems
to be suggested throughout do I think
there is a possibility well certainly it
is a possibility but in my mind it's a
possibility that would require the
following
it would require this reality to be a
deliberately created reality and not a
spontaneous naturalistic unfolding of
what is not a product of nature but an
artificial Creation with rules set in a
premeditated premeditated way for a
deliberate purpose
in other words a kind of theater that
was set up for a purpose
by a meta conscious intelligence that's
what it would require do I see external
empirical evidence for it no not do I
see conceptual reasons to entertain the
possibility no none
do I have intuitions every now and then
that resonate with this possibility yes
I do yeah
and so
if we if we take that again so let's say
we go back to this notion of of
metacognition as being in some ways a
fall and a narrow way but there is also
a manner in which
we Act
once we have it we act in relationship
to that that is that for example
spontaneous intelligence uh a Berserker
has spontaneous intelligence right
that's actually a good example like the
Berserker enters into a state of flow
where they can kill indeterminately with
a strength of of 10 men and and it's a
it's an ecstatic moment uh but but so so
there's a sense with that natural
intelligence or that that spontaneous
intelligence that we see in animals does
not have this does not have a
a sense of the good at least not the way
that that we do
um yeah and so and so once we have that
then we act that's why it's also the
knowledge of Good and Evil that's why at
least in Scripture it it is related to
it is a fall but it is also an entering
into something which can bring
more let's say we value judgments more
yes exactly and so
yeah and so so that's why I because the
the thing I'm worried about in the way
you describe it is that if if we if we
don't let's say
I'll say I'll say it in very in very
gross religious terms like if we don't
have a God that's good
then we have a problem down the line
which is that at some point there's no
justification there's no ultimate
justification
for the superiority of our of our
ethical intuitions to the intuition that
would drive a Berserker to rape and
pillage and kill everybody in a village
you know and so where does the
where does the sense of of the
superiority of one over the other like
what is that even where does that come
from
most of what you you will see or hear me
argue
is what I cannot give for based on
analytic reasoning and evidence and if
you put me against the wall and a gun to
my head and say okay now make your best
bet about what's going on if you're
wrong I'm gonna shoot you then that's
the position I would hold the position
informed by analytic reasoning and an
empirical objective evidence
but I entertain other possibilities in
my mind which I don't talk about because
I can't argue for them
I cannot write a book by saying well I
have an intuition that it isn't that
yeah okay yeah thank you very much but
why do I care right why would they
really care
um
so I I would
try to defend the point you're making
from an analytic perspective
which doesn't mean that I completely
reject the point you're making okay
um I'll just try to do my best to defend
it from an analytic perspective
I think
the responsibility for morals for
Morality
in a naturalistic universe in other
words a universe that unfolds
spontaneously because it is what it is
as opposed to an artificially set up
environment that follows a premeditated
plan
in a naturalistic universe
the responsibility for moral judgment is
stronger
for us
then it is in a universe created by a
meta-conscious Divinity that has its own
moral book
because in the latter case
we are just ignorant somebody has the
the right answers
so the responsibility lies more with
that entity which then raises questions
like if God knows what's good why does
it allow the Berserker to do what it
does
who has ultimate moral responsibility
for the Berserker doing what he does the
Berserker you and I or The God Who
created this whole thing and set it all
up who has the moral responsibility for
what's happening in Ukraine right now in
a universe that was
meta-consciously and in a premedited
premeditated way set up by a thinking
self-conscious Divinity is it you and I
is it putting or is it the Divinity that
allowed for a Putin to exist in in this
reality
in a naturalistic universe universe the
responsibility is ours
including the Berserker and now you
might ask well how do I know who has the
best moral call the Berserker or me
there is no outside answer for that
question that's the price you pay in a
naturalistic Universe
um
Nietzsche has been brilliant in the late
19th century
picking apart Christian morals
um and to this day it's difficult to
refute some of the things he says from
Pure purely logical and evidence-based
perspective
um and that was the genius of Nietzsche
that he could just trounce things that
seem to be morally obvious to us
and and and and actually defend the very
opposite you know the Superman the the
morals of the strong as opposed of as
opposed to slave morality
so the answer is I don't have an answer
uh Jonathan I just
would defend the notion that whatever
the answer is the responsibility for
finding the answer is ours we carry the
ultimate moral responsibility in a
naturalistic universe that has no
pre-written book of moral codes
because people tend to think that unless
morals are etched in stone before the
rise of human beings then morals don't
exist the moral responsibility doesn't
exist unless it's grounded on something
prior and external I would argue the
opposite it's the very fact that in a
naturalistic universe there is no tables
of moral codes it's that very fact that
imbues in us the ultimate Supreme moral
responsibility
uh to the the responsibility for
Discerning between good and evil the
responsibility for reacting to what
Putin is doing now
so it's not a satisfactory answer but
it's the best no no no I but I I
understand and I think that you you
obviously put your finger on the most
difficult question like the the problem
of evil or the problem of suffering is
definitely always the one that makes
all religious people you know stand back
and and and and wonder and and question
because
that is a definitely a
that is definitely something that the
way that Christians would
would defend the the the answer would be
that it is something that is related
to the fall somehow that there's a
relationship to the fall that we have an
intuition in US
that there should things should be
different
okay at least frame it that way that
things that there's something awry about
the way things are there's something
which is not aiming properly towards the
good that isn't properly aligned towards
the good and we represent it in this in
this story of of the Fall
um
and so there is a sense in which the the
fact that things are not good is due to
is actually due to us
so I I do think that in the also in the
Christian cosmology like the real
Christians cosmology if there's a sense
in which their responsibility does come
back onto us because although it's not
you can't it's not something that you
can describe scientifically because it
if you try to do it it gets weird but
that intuition is real the intuition
that something is wrong isn't right
um and and we have the the
responsibility to
aim ourselves towards the good and that
that is the best thing we can do to
to reshape the world let's say and if
we're willing to to end it of course the
image of Christ ends up being the
Ultimate Image in the Christian
cosmology of of that it's actually
through self-sacrifice that that this
will happen that if you that if you are
able to give yourself
um to the good
then that's the best thing you can do
but I agree that that for many people
that that's not enough especially in a
in a scientific frame because they'll
say things like like you know things
have been dying and eating each other
and killing each other for millions and
millions of years before
humans woke up let's say
um but nonetheless I think that if we
understand it more as as an experience
I would say that would be the the best
way that I would frame it there is
something you said earlier
that there is some theology suggesting
that the fall in and of itself was not
bad it it was the timing it was too
early it was before we were prepared for
it right we're eating or eating the
fruit was before we were ready yeah
if we interpret the fall as the fall
into metacognitions in metacognition
then I would say empirically that's
obviously true
we broke our relationship with the
harmony of instinct
before we were prepared and what
happened was that uh we became able to
develop technology because of
metacognition
but without
the empathy required to apply that
technology wisely as opposed to that
very narrowly contracted field of
personal benefit which is exactly what
we leverage when we use technology
so it's yeah the fall happened before
it was a good move on the part of nature
or on the part of the divinity
it was too early and the evidence for
that is life as we leave it today and
the risks that we bring to ourselves and
everything else that lives on the
surface of this planet the fall is
Nature's biggest gamble if it was a
Gamble or Nature's potential biggest
mistake if it was a mistake
and from that perspective I think the
language of we are born in sin makes
sense not in a literal sense but to your
born in sinning so far as we are born
metacognizant
um
having said that and while acknowledging
that metacognition is is the the
founding head of suffering psychological
suffering
there is this other thing that is
horrible and doesn't depend on
metacognition at Spain
and and nature has
copious amounts of it you know I I
always refer to this documentary that
impressed me very much a few years ago a
pride of lions isolated a grown elephant
from from its group
and brought it down and ate this
elephant from the hind legs upwards for
six hours before the elephant passed out
that's nature you know earthworms are
being cut alive into wiggling Pieces by
ants in your backyard every day
um that's not good if you ask me if I
were the Divinity and if I were meta
conscious
I wouldn't do that on the other hand and
that's when I surrender to everything
you said
what we consider good or bad is largely
dependent on scope
if you don't have a broad enough scope
to see how what seems very bad locally
is automatically good then you can't
make a wise moral judgment the
philosophers have a problem that
illustrates this the problem is the
following there is a trend coming and
there is a y split on the railway and on
the one side of the split there is a guy
tied down to the rails and on the other
side there are four guys tied down to
the rails
and the railway setup in such a way that
the train is going to go to the one guy
as opposed to the far and it's going to
kill that one guy but the other four
Will Survive and you have your hands on
the lever that allows so sorry the train
would go to the four guys would kill the
four guys if you don't do anything
and the one guy would survive you have
the hands on the lever and you can
switch the rail line in such a way that
the train kills only the one and not the
four yeah but now you're killing it now
you are the one and you only see you you
don't see the other four
he only sees himself and you with your
hands on the lever and he sees you
moving the liver so the train goes to
you to him
from his narrow scope you have committed
and in an unfathomable Act of evil
but from a broader scope you've taken
the decision that one should take
so who are we to judge who are we to
judge whether that elephant shouldn't
have suffered for six hours
I have to I have to go but I I love this
guy thank you so much for this
conversation Bernardo I I think like I
still feel like we're always just
scratching the surface though that's the
thing we do a third round I enjoy it
very much I really enjoy it I appreciate
it and I'd definitely be willing to to
go for another round so thanks so much
and thanks Marcus for organizing this
well thank you Jonathan thank you
Bernardo it's been a pleasure to listen
to you both for the most part again and
um yeah I'd love to do it again with you
guys of course
um online number one and uh number two I
was thinking if either of you are
interested in coming to Ireland they say
next year for an impression event that
would be fantastic I know we had a great
event recently with Paul vandertley and
Paul Kings North and that so God willing
we can make it happen and I don't know
if you have any interest in that I would
definitely be I mean I'll be probably
traveling a few times to the UK the next
year and so if we can organize it I
would love that I know how bernardo's
probably super busy too but if it could
work I'll be there
I I cannot promise I would even say it's
unlikely I get
them I would say
I have to deal with lots of requests
yeah which is a great honor and it's not
something I complain about at all it's
humbling
uh but every time I have to jump on a
plane it's not only the time of the
event but two days before and two days
after yeah and that can be very tricky
so I'm not going to promise you on the
other hand one of the holes in my life
is I have never visited Ireland have
gone around the world multiple times and
I haven't been directly acquainted with
the green fields of Ireland so who knows
no problem thank you so much again gents
and have a lovely evening God bless you
thank you guys all right